okay so the topic of this video is gonna
be mutations DNA misspellings DNA errors
that's what mutations are let's go ahead
and get started as we go through this
video you're gonna want to have a copy
of the genetic code with you whether you
have it in your textbook or whether you
google the words genetic code and print
out a diagram like this it's going to be
really helpful to have this alongside of
you as we go through this video I'm also
going to assume that you have a general
understanding of how transcription and
translation works because you're gonna
see transcription and translation
discussed in this video so if you're not
quite sure what the process of
transcription and translation are you
may want to watch those videos first
before we before you try to tack on this
video so let's get started
okay so I first want to discuss a point
mutation well in the animation what you
see happening is the process of
transcription the black letters across
the top are DNA the red letters that
were created our messenger RNA and so
transcription just occurred and what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to underline
starting with the letters Aug if you
remember Aug is the start codon and I'm
gonna underline every three letters what
every three nucleotides again I'm gonna
underline what are called codons and the
ribosome will read the Lakota Aug and
transfer RNA will deliver the amino acid
called methionine the ribosome will read
the codon you see see look up you see
see on your genetic code chart and
transfer RNA will deliver serine the
ribosome will read GAA look up GAA on
your chart transfer RNA will deliver
glutamic acid the ribosome will read the
codon AGC transfer RNA will deliver
serine the ribosome will read the next
codon CCG transfer RNA will deliver
prolene and then the ribosome comes to
UGA and that's a stop codon right there
so this is this was a review of
transcription and translation now what I
want to mention now is what are point
mutations a point mutation is where one
nucleotide is substituted for another so
at the bottom are the same strip of
black DNA letters and notice how I've
just changed one of the letters one of
the nucleotides you can see in the the
letters on top it was originally that
that T that's pulsing originally was an
a so we're gonna pretend that in this
mutation the T that's pulsing and
flashing that's a mistake it's not
supposed to be a T it's supposed to be
an a so we have a misspelling in our DNA
one thing I want to mention is that
misspellings are in errors or mutations
like this are often repaired by
spellchecker enzymes but what I want to
show you today is what happens when
they're not
this might lead to a change in amino
acids which could have a drastic impact
on the overall protein so through the
process of transcription the red letters
are forming that's messenger RNA is
being formed the messenger RNA will
break away and move to a ribosome and
I'm gonna underline starting with Aug
I'm gonna underline every three
nucleotides and so the ribosome will
read the codon Aug transfer RNA will
deliver methionine
just like we see and above but now we
come to the mutated codon above in the
top of the picture the code I'm supposed
to be you see see for the amino acid
serine but because of that misspelling
in the DNA it's not you cc anymore it's
now a CC transfer RNA is not going to
deliver serine in this example it's
gonna deliver threonine the ribosome
goes to the third codon well the GAA
codon is the same that hasn't been
mutated so that's still glutamic acid
the fourth codon is the same it hasn't
been mutated that's still serine and the
fifth codon is the same that hasn't
changed that's still prolene and then we
code outcome the codon number six and
that's still the stop codon so that one
change
it's supposed to be serine on top but
you see because of that mistake its
threonine I'm gonna explain why that's a
big deal in just a moment but before I
do explain why that's a big deal that
one changed amino acid I want to show
what's called a silent mutation first
here's again a strip of black DNA
letters and here's our misspelling
here's our mutation you can see it's the
flashing letter a it's not supposed to
be an a an the strip above on top you
can see it's supposed to be a G but
because of this misspelling this
mutation it's now an a for adenine
through the process of transcription
messenger RNA is going to be created
notice how the messenger RNA is now also
misspelled it's flashing in in red the
red you it that's a misspelling there
again the the messenger RNA was using
the DNA
as a template so the red mRNA goes to a
ribosome I'm gonna underline every three
letters and the ribosome reads the codon
Aug that hasn't changed it's still
methionine but now we come to the codon
with the flashing letter U on top you
can see it was supposed to be UCC for
the amino acid serine but because of the
misspelling it's not UCC anymore it's
you see you which if you look on your
genetic code chart it's still serine
this is what we mean by a silent
mutation there's a clear misspelling but
it's silent in that there's no impact
the person got lucky because the amino
acid has not changed you see see and you
see you they are both codons for the
amino acid serine so you go to the third
codon GAA that's glutamic acid nothing
changed the fourth codon is the same
that's the codon for serine the fifth
codons the same that hasn't changed it's
prolene and then we come to the sixth
codon that's our stop codon so this
person has a clear misspelling the clear
DNA mutation but this is what we mean by
a silent mutation it didn't cause any
impact any change to their proteins okay
now I want to go back and explain why
just one wrong amino acid can be a
really big deal and have drastic side
effects you may have heard of the
protein called hemoglobin well
hemoglobin is a protein found in red
blood cells that helps red blood cells
carry oxygen around your body protein
hemoglobin excuse me hemoglobin is a
protein and like all proteins are made
from a bunch of amino acids in fact
hemoglobin is made from 574 amino acids
now if you've heard of a sickle cell
disease sickle cell is caused when when
up people with this disease one amino
acid has been changed in that entire
strip of 574 and because of one wrong
amino acid they can have a
life-threatening disorder let me show
you how this works
in top rDNA letters and through the
process of transcription will make these
letters beneath it of messenger RNA the
messenger RNA will go to a ribosome and
the ribosome will read
Guu and that's the code for Val what
stands for valine the ribosome reads ca
you and that's histidine the next one in
blue is leucine and orange its threonine
and pink it's prolene and the last two
in that kind of yellow color are
glutamic acid so this is the normal
coding for people who have normal
hemoglobin and if you hemoglobins normal
your red blood cells will look like this
round perfectly and I should say
perfectly round but nice round red blood
cells carry an oxygen all around your
body may you live happily ever after but
now here's where people have sickle cell
disease look at this there's a
misspelling I've highlighted it with the
red letter A you can see in the normal
cell the code is supposed to be C TT but
in sickle cell people have the code C
eighty so through the process of
transcription when they make messenger
RNA you can see the messenger RNA is now
GU a in the normal cell above the
messenger RNA is supposed to be GAA but
because of the misspelling it's now GU a
so through the process of translation
the transfer RNA is going to bring over
in this case the wrong amino acid you
can see where we get to that the one two
three four five six we get to the sixth
codon the GU a that is if you look up GU
a on the chart that's the code for
valine that's the wrong amino acid you
can see the normal cell on top there's
supposed to be two glutamic acids
back-to-back Glu Glu Glu back to back
but people at sickle-cell one of the one
of the amino acids has been changed it's
been changed to valine and because of
that one change their red blood cells
look like this banana shape
or sickle-shaped if you ever seen a
sickle it's like a blade with a curved
curvature to it and so because of this
the people have a a life-threatening
disorder called sickle cell disease 574
amino acids and one of them is wrong so
this process of assembling amino acids
has to be perfect this is a great
example of what can go wrong if just one
amino acid has been cheap the next type
of mutation I want to mention is what's
called a frame shift mutation you know
it started off the same way we have red
messenger RNA being created through
transcription and I'm gonna have the
ribosome read every three letters at a
time so starting with Aug that's the
code from a thiamine you see see that's
the code for serine GAA that's the code
for glutamic acid AGC that's the code
for serine CCG that's the code for
prolene and then UGA is a stop codon
well what a frameshift mutation is it's
where a nucleotide gets inserted or
accidentally deleted from an entire
strip of DNA and so the entire sequence
after the DNA or the RNA is mutated is
gonna be shifted and altered and you'll
see what I mean by this in a moment with
my animation so on the bottom here's an
example of a frameshift mutation where a
letter is gonna be deleted so here is
the same letters in black the same DNA
letters in black that you see notice how
I have the T flashing the reason for
that T flashing watch what happens
accidentally that T for thymine is gonna
be deleted notice all the other letters
after shifted down so why is this gonna
make a big deal a big difference well
through the process of transcription the
red messenger RNA is gonna be created
and again I'm gonna underline
starting with Aug I'm gonna underline
every three nucleotides that's called a
codon and the red mrna goes to a
ribosome and Aug when it's read by the
ribosome
that's the amino acid methionine UCC is
serine GAA
is glutamic acid so far nothing's
changed if you look at the top picture
look at the bottom picture they're
identical but here's where all the
changes start to happen because of the
removal of that T the letters have
completely shifted so now we have GC C
the code for alanine the next codon cgu
is for arginine the next codon was
supposed to be a stop codon they were
supposed to be a stop codon Aug a stop
codon but because of the shift the next
codon is now GAC for aspartic acid the
next codon is now histidine the stop
codon has been basically destroyed so
this ribosome doesn't know to stop
creating the the protein stopped
assembling amino acids so ultimately the
ribosome just keeps on going and
eventually it runs out of messenger RNA
to read and the protein that's created
that you might even call a nonsense
protein because it's gonna be a very
very dysfunctional if any function
whatsoever so here's an example of a
frameshift insertion kind of the same
result but instead of deleting a letter
we're gonna insert a letter watch this
here comes T for thiamine that just got
accidentally inserted I'm gonna have it
blink the whole time so we can keep our
eye on it so that fourth T is not
supposed to be there in the picture on
top you can see there supposed to be
three T's in a row TTT
but because of that insertion it's now
tttt there's four T's so through the
process of transcription red messenger
RNA is going to be created and notice
what happens is that that fourth T will
lead to the creation of a fourth a well
the right the messenger RNA will go to
the ribosome I'm gonna underline every
three letters at a time codons and the
ribosome will read Aug that's methionine
the ribosome will read you see
see that searing so far everything's
fine the ribosome reads GAA that's
glutamic acid so far we're fine but now
here's where the shift occurred because
of inserting that T where it doesn't
belong everything after the T was
shifted and so now the codon is a AG for
lysine the next codon is CCC for prolene
again we're supposed to have a stop
codon next the stop codon was supposed
to be UGA but because of the shift
because of the addition the insertion of
that extra T that extra nucleotide it
basically ruined and destroyed the stop
codon it's now GU G for valine the next
codon is now a CC for threonine the next
codons
auu for isoleucine the ribosome didn't
know to stop because the stop codon was
basically destroyed so this protein that
would be created again would pretty much
be a nonsense unfunctional protein and
so as I just mentioned stop codons are
often lost as a result of a frameshift
mutation and there are proteins that are
created I've said this a few times are
often non-functional due to the large
number of incorrect amino acids maybe
the protein is just too big now it's
only supposed to be made from maybe five
amino acids but now it's made from 20
amino acids so frameshift mutations are
a lot more serious well what about a
chromosome mutation the frame shift and
the point mutations these are mutations
that happen to individual genes what
about a chromosome mutation well there's
a process called translocation and this
is where chromosome segments will
combine with non homologous chromosomes
so I have two non homologous chromosomes
chromosome five in blue chromosome eight
which is a little smaller in red or
excuse me chromosome eight in green and
what happens during translocation is
that genes of one chromosome end up
entirely completely different
chromosomes watch this through the
process of trail
location a portion of chromosome five
may actually break off and combine the
chromosome number eight so now you have
genes that are supposed to be on
chromosome five now attached to
chromosome number eight and often what
happens in this process is that an
entire gene might be destroyed for
instance the AUG start code might be on
chromosome five but the UGA stop code
now might be on chromosome number eight
so the the the gene was literally ripped
apart with half of the gene on
chromosome five and half of the gene on
chromosome number eight so you can
imagine if that's the case the gene if
it was cut apart the gene is not going
to be a functional gene anymore the
person is not going to have the benefit
of this protein that they're supposed to
have so if you chapter chapters ago we
discussed karyotypes pictures of a
person's chromosomes well here is a
karyotype of a person with Down syndrome
now we've seen Down syndrome karyotypes
before they have personal a Down
syndrome whether it's a male or female
has three chromosome 21s well when you
look at when you look at this and you
find chromosome 21 I only see two of
them but if you look harder there's a
third chromosome 21 there's one
chromosome 21 right there on the left
there is a second chromosome 21 right
there
the third chromosome is part of Trent
has been translocated and a chromosome
14 so this person still has Down
syndrome even though it may not look
like it they still have three chromosome
21s it's just one of the chromosome 21s
has been translocated under and attached
to coma zone 14 so is a great example of
translocation from a moment ago
so what impact would this have on
offspring well first of all it depends
on what kind of mutations we're looking
at our mutations are they in somatic
cells remember what somatic cells are
skin cells and nerve cells muscle cells
blood cells somatic cells are body cells
somatic cells are non sex cells and so
these mutations only affect the
individual here we see a person with a
pretty nasty sunburn
well sunburns can eventually over time
if you have repeated and serious enough
of sunburns can cause skin cancer
mutations can occur and can cause you to
develop skin cancer
now pretend that this guy right here our
cartoon guy due to years of sunbathing
this male developed skin cancer his wife
recently gave birth to this boy that we
see here
well this child also inherit the skin
cancer mutation that the father has I
hope you see the answer to this question
would be no in this case B ghin that the
father developed skin cancer maybe
because of that because of his lifestyle
of sunbathing so if if a mutation is
only in a somatic cell well somatic cell
DNA is not passed on to future
generations you don't make a child from
DNA of somatic cells you make a child
from DNA of the gametes the sperm and
the egg so in order for a mutation to be
passed on from parent to child
that mutation has to be in the sperm or
the egg so if we look at what germ cells
are again and germ cells aren't what you
think they are again when we hear the
word germ we think of gross viruses and
bacteria we got to wash our hands but
that's not what germ cells are earlier
in the school year we talked about germ
cells they are the diploid cells that
will undergo meiosis to fur males to
make sperm and for females to make eggs
so in in the male reproductive system
there are germ cells that will go
through meiosis to make sperm and in the
female reproductive system there are
germ cells that will go through meiosis
to make the eggs or the ovum
and so in my animation here here we have
about seven or eight or nine sperm cells
and I have one of them with an M inside
because we're gonna pretend that this
this sperm cell with an M that's also
flashing and pulsing but the M stands
for it has a mutation in its DNA the
other sperm cells are fine but this
sperm cell pretend has a mutation now if
this sperm cell with the mutation were
to fertilize the egg which would then
become a zygote and develop into a fetus
and then a baby
yeah then eventually this person that is
born whether it's a male or female if
they very well could inherit this
mutation because the mutation was in a
sperm cell in this case of course it
could work the other way around maybe
mom maybe mom's ovum had a mutation and
of course that could be passed on to to
the child as well but the point I want
to mention is that mutations are only
passed on if there's a mutation to a
sperm or an egg if the germ cells that
make the sperm and egg have a mutation
then those sperm and egg very well could
be mutated which could lead to the the
child inheriting some sort of DNA error
so what causes these mutations well
let's try to avoid them well it's not
entirely easy to avoid some of these
things that cause mutations well first
of all just general objects that cause
mutations are what we call mutagens and
so the reason for this picture I love
this picture this is a picture of our
son given off UV light and I bring up UV
light because UV energy UV radiation is
a known mutagen it's a known mutation
causing object or energy I should say
and so what I have often happens is
mutagens they speed up the replication
process the process of DNA making a copy
of itself is often sped up because of
mutagens which could increase the chance
for error and it also causes mutagens
also causing new
Oh tides to break apart and when they
break apart they often will recombine in
in wrong patterns and so the animation
shows here this the sunlight sunlight is
being absorbed into our skin let's say
you're at the ocean then you're enjoying
a day at the beach and you forgot to put
on the sunscreen now you're not wearing
a long shirt you're not underneath an
umbrella and you've been exposed to Sun
for a long time and watch what happens
when your Sun ups when your skin absorbs
UV rays what it causes is it causes di
your DNA molecules to break apart aids
and the T's separate from one another
and so UV UV radiation is a known what
is called a mutagen and so of course you
want to limit your exposure to mutagens
such as such as UV so if you are gonna
be at the beach of course we're sun's
sunscreen and not just once when you get
there you may be at the beach all day
you may spend 10 hours at the beach so
you have to reapply of course the the
sunscreen according to the directions on
the bottle of course there's other
protections you could take you know
wearing lip balm and wearing sunglasses
and wearing a hat and sitting underneath
an umbrella and a light long-sleeve
shirt you know these are things that you
can and you can do to limit your
exposure to UV which again is a known
mutagen so there you go if you're in my
biology class hit the pause video and
try to answer these questions and I'd
love to check your answers for accuracy
either before school or after school one
day good luck